okay another fact check that i want to
do
this is a really good opportunity to
talk about this new talking point
that is spreading that only 9 000
americans died of coronavirus now you
might hear that and say
oh 9 000. 180 something thousand
is the official death toll where on
earth are you getting that
i'm going to tell you exactly where it
comes from and in fact
donald trump tried amplifying this
talking point and
a tweet that twitter removed because it
was spreading disinformation
about coronavirus 19. so the original
tweet was posted
by a user with the username littlemel
has been removed and it now says this
tweet is no longer available because it
violated the twitter rules
the story that that tweet which donald
trump retweeted
told is one that alleges that
new cdc data proves coronavirus
was only the cause of death in 6
of the deaths so far and that for all
other coronavirus deaths
the real cause of death was one two or
even
three other conditions or causes and
what
a lot of right wingers are seizing on is
that six percent number and saying
look only nine thousand people really
died
of coronavirus now that tweet was
removed
donald trump also retweeted a post by
one of
his attorneys jenna ellis with a link to
a story on a far-right conspiracy
website
also based on the same coronavirus 19
conspiracy
that retweet hasn't been removed and it
says
if you're looking very dramatically
shock report
the the cdc quietly updated covid
numbers
only 9200 died from coronavirus
alone the rest had different other
serious illnesses
now i'm going to explain the talking
point to you
but i actually wonder do you think trump
believes only 9 000 people really died
of coronavirus
or do you think he's retweeting this
stuff because he knows that there's a
political advantage to doing it i
actually am unsure
but it boggles the mind how anyone could
look at the data and say oh
these people didn't really die of
coronavirus so
let me give you an analogy to what they
are saying this would be like saying
most gunshot victims don't die of a
gunshot
they die of bleeding out and so gunshots
aren't really that deadly but listen if
you're gonna bleed out that's a
completely different story
that's essentially the argument that
they are making what they are trying to
say is
the 94 of coronavirus deaths
that had an additional comorbidity
weren't really coronavirus deaths and of
course this misses the point that
the way lots of people end up dying from
communicable disease
is because they have an underlying
compromised immune system
or they have another condition that
makes the virus or whatever disease
we're talking about more dangerous or
deadly and
the idea they're trying to spread is if
you're healthy you don't really have
anything to worry about
and therefore we don't need to be doing
all the social distancing we don't need
masks we don't need shutdowns we don't
need any of this stuff
now there's a couple different reactions
to this first of all
forty percent of americans are obese and
obesity is an aggravating factor for
coronavirus so
if you want the make the to make the
case that if you have no comorbidity
you were really really safe um 40
of americans have a major comorbidity
with which is obesity so
even if this was accurate in some way in
some
fundamental sense it doesn't seem like
this gets a lot of people off the hook
that's number one
number two this is something
that if it were to become widely
believed
would be very dangerous because it would
simply encourage
dangerous behavior including from people
who do have comorbidities
a lot of people don't even understand
the concept of a co-morbidity
and risk factors and aggravating factors
so
this would be the type of stuff that
twitter should be policing in general
but not that what you would expect to
see posted by a president of the united
states
but it is indeed being posted by the
president of the united states and
twitter is regularly having
to actually deal with donald trump's
tweets another retweet from trump was
recently removed
for falsely claiming that there was a
cure for coronavirus
twitter moderators have also had to deal
with donald trump's tweets
um that were glorifying violence the
reality is donald trump if he were not
president
likely would have been banned from
twitter a long time ago and yet they
continue to insist that twitter's bias
is actually
an anti-conservative more than it is uh
and anti-liberal
very very weird stuff